[Music]
branch hey hi hello everyone welcome
back to lobby games last weekly video
game hangout I'm back I was gone for two
weeks he's a far land of New York yeah
I'm back it's good to be back I heard
you guys went like two hours last time
yeah cuz we were having so much fun yeah
well hopefully that pertains to the
audience as well I'm sure it did as
always we have a giveaway today we have
some news items to get through but it is
kind of Destiny to week and also Metroid
Samus Returns
Pete and I got the chance to play it we
have a lot of things to talk about with
that that'll be out September 15th on
3ds but we also have some posts PAX West
did it call it X prime X prime pax
it's all back south now pax Australia
East X New Guinea we will be talking
about kind of there's a few smaller
announcements there and also just
overall impressions of the show Kelly
you were gracious enough to come into
the office while you're reviewing
destiny to I'm sure it's a busy week so
far we're all kind of playing destiny to
in one respect or another but I wanna
get through some news items in some good
news for player unknown Brendan green
the game reached 10 million copies sold
yesterday
in six months yeah he sent out a tweet
yesterday because seven million is like
wow that's unreal and then all of a
sudden yesterday he just goes holy wow I
think he like found out and then
immediately holy [ __ ] we just reached 10
million so player nodes battlegrounds
still doesn't have any
hasn't released their second map the
desert one is he's just too busy playing
his own game
probably yeah it's still early access
they say they're gonna be out in full
before the end of the year Xbox one
version as well at some point they still
don't have solid dates such as the
nature of early access sometimes but
yeah congratulations to Brendan green
and all the people at a Blue Hole
involve that game in South Korea blue
hole yeah blue point is the HD remake um
yeah I don't know if the audience hears
this audio but jean-luc you're piping in
some weird audio into this video is it a
cry for help
thank you being attacked very loud
there's very loud music playing in our
studio it's done now you're okay John
Luke so
also mario the famed Italian plumber
apparently it's not plumber anymore yeah
well they were like people were talking
about his costumes and Odyssey how he
can have like a safari outfit and what
not and then Nintendo their Japanese
website says he's no longer doing
professional plumbing work as you could
see on screen if you're watching live
the page explains Mario as such
all-around sporty whether it's tennis or
baseball soccer or car racing he does
everything cool as a matter of fact he
also seems has worked as a plumber a
long time ago as a matter of fact he has
evolved I like the counterpoint to him
being sporty was as a matter of fact
yeah he was a plumber I like that I like
that plumber I'd be pissed I can be
sporty yeah it's pretty neat progression
tree dolly plumber and then we're
racecar driver
Tarun Singh Mario Kart am I just getting
this like Mario Kart he's a noted
partier I've heard what you realize you
don't sleep the whole world opens up I
didn't get to play Mario Plus rabbits
yes which is a shame because I've heard
it's very good is he a plumber in that
like did they not to like get too deep
into this right well there are pipes
yeah that he can go in so he's a green
beret in that what is a plumber they
fixed like wiring wiring electricity oh
boy no cable antenna everyone drink
coffee all night cool so yeah Mario's
not a plumber anymore
he's very jack-of-all-trades it's pretty
awesome quote yeah so PACs how was did
you Kelly you're the only one here that
went to pax I believe okay how was it it
was fun it's a very chill show this is
my first pax it was nice uh I was sort
of nervous and then I found the Pokemon
League which made me feel more at home
yeah you can go around challenge people
to Pokemon
when you're not doing other things but
yes cool the panels are cool I went to
The Witcher 10-year anniversary panel my
Jenny was the most attended one there
right yeah it was it was huge and tons
of people there yeah that theater that I
was in I've only been there once my
first and only PAX West or whatever was
two years ago and that theater I'm
terrified of heights and the balcony
seats there have like there has such a
steep incline that I actually got like
convert ago in that theater but it looks
packed from photos side tangent put that
theater terrifies me yeah it's huge it's
like they have actual art and stuff
there they do real performances so like
the fear is I'm sorry the fears like the
are gonna trip down yes steps yes
there's like six rows of balconies
already six rows up candles ticking in
1880 Parker like that the top section is
I just you think about like like if
you're just a drunk [ __ ] just like
people just dying that's why they call
them the nosebleeds anyway I got to
check out a lot of cool stuff I play I
think what my favorite thing I saw one
of my favorite things was donut County
which is like reverse Katamari you it's
like a town with like anthropomorphic
animals and very cute but you control a
hole in the ground and you can like you
go under things so they fall into the
hole and the more things you collect the
bigger the hole gets until you clean up
everything and it was really fun I liked
it a lot
what does a hole with nothing left to
fall through it cleared level what is
the hole but the absence of space or the
center of Earth were there there were
announcements right a couple smaller
ones oh this was a game you're talking
about I thought you were saying it was
some sort of booth or like restaurant
Seattle this is deeper than it yeah this
is very much a black a black hole right
he's a very smart raccoon he should be
running he's very smart
I also he is the hole
going on and then I also got to play
something called battle chef brigade
which is the next like Adult Swim games
the next game that they're doing very
good name it is an anime style
match-three brawler cooking competition
game and it rules I like to know that
you said it's also and it probably
wasn't an indie thing was it no it is
coming to switch it might have been on
the Ninh Dee's thing actually yeah I
think it was but I got to play it and I
thought that match-three brawler stuff
would not work but it worked really well
actually
you basically have to like go hunt for
ingredients you have to get the right
combination of ingredients to cook and
there's three colors and those you have
to match them to get a good dish and it
had like a story
you're like an up-and-coming chef it
reminded me of food Wars that anime it
was like iron chef sort of it was as
cool a cool switch game or the brawler
and come into play after you Mayhew when
you hunt for food you have to like
attack animals and stuff and steal their
meat the only match three like fighting
game I played with dungeons dungeon
dragons dragons dragons dragons puzzle
and Dragons brawling in it not brawling
no because you replace super puzzle
final but super puzzle fighter 2 turbo
nope No so you know Street Fighter
obviously yes was it's basically like
Puyo Puyo in a sense that you have to
like match up like you know for things
that fall and drop but like the bigger
the thing you destroy the more like you
have to Street Fighter characters on the
screen it said their actions are
dictated by what you break so it's like
a fighting game driven by puzzle
mechanics interesting what about a No
More Heroes the new it's not a
reimagining it's a sequel right from
pseudo 50s that off it packs yeah that
trailer is sick I love the art style I
didn't get to you check out the game
myself I think all of saundra might have
checked that out but the
well it went away the trailer the
trailer is really cool and I haven't
played know where heroes it kind of made
me want to know I did see in the in the
fact that like I feel like I slept on
this this seems like something I would
really enjoy and I want to be able to
check it out before this comes out so
one of the points of confusion that was
recently cleared up around this for
people who don't know this sort of hints
that like a hotline Miami like
collaboration and there was like some
talk over like oh yeah we're gonna be
collaborating with like seven different
indie dev studios to make this game
that's not true
they're collaborating with seven indie
devs to make t-shirts that you can wear
in the game which is a huge difference
different than what I thought yeah I
didn't care about this because I was
like oh they're gonna democratize
development [ __ ] that
but no they're not it's it's a suit a
joint it is what he's doing you prefer
totalitarian development you mean art
the I played I played shadows the Damned
I played killer7 mm-hmm and I played
part of No More Heroes yeah and they
never really grabbed me all that much
but this looks very stylish I mean if
anything they're distinct right like
they leave an impression on you and you
remember what you've played which is
more than I can say for some games so
you know just to have something so
unique and get the budget to be made the
way it is I'm happy to see that yeah
what was the recent game he made that
everyone was like [ __ ] on but
probably good let it die yeah that was
that was a weird it was free to play was
like you're he's like you're
quarter-sized your guide kind of yeah
that was uh that was a fun game kind of
procedurally it's generated in amusment
park I kind of I don't know you die
there's permadeath and then you go back
to the beginning but yeah you're trying
to survive and get through it's fun it's
interesting how that game is kind of
disappeared yeah but despite the fact
that people are still playing it yeah it
kind of had a drop off I guess then we
also is there anything else from pax
that I missed overall there was a new
Secret of Mana footage stream yeah
thought the remake really yeah what's
that coming to ps4 PC and Vita not
switch that's on the semester class ik
as well really original yeah yeah that's
why played that game once I liked it a
lot what did they show I packed this
really the first 10 minutes on a stream
and there was English subtitles which is
good and it looks great to me like
Justin speaking to Justin hey wolde he
correctly noted that it sort of looks
like what you'd get from like square
enix is like mobile 3d remakes oh really
but that doesn't really that doesn't
bother me so much
frankly mobile 3d yeah remakes yeah I'm
thinking of like well sure yes no no
think about that think about like the DS
Final Fantasy games that they read me
now sort of but like but nobody it's
it's higher quality it's like a G it's
sort of chibi look it's GB it's cartoony
but it's I mean it's not like highly
detailed but it's certainly expressive
enough so I don't know there might be
two different camps that you know for me
it seemed like a very faithful 3d
upgrade cool so I'm excited about it so
pax fun show fun yes yeah ttle and you
you stayed up there or no did you do it
when did you go to Bungie for that
preview review that was three weeks ago
okay yeah when I did that for take the
taken king it was like I stayed up there
for the next few days at Bunyan oh yeah
I yeah pax is like I did all that and
then I went straight into destiny some
kind of yeah and I had the Pokemon thing
I did yeah I am tired will be yeah we'll
be getting more in depth at destiny too
later in the show probably the last
segment also be talking about Metroid
Samus Returns and Nintendo in general
they're having a great year
by all accounts I'm gonna knock this off
because I had embargo for tomorrow but
subside no equivalent Metroid and I
guess just like Nintendo general uh I
haven't really always been the biggest
Fire Emblem fan that's telling you and
Jake cuz Jake's always like ranting
about Fire Emblem I played a little bit
awakening back in the day I never played
any of Eight's games revelations
conquest of birth right two years ago
Fire Emblem echoes like jumped up to my
top ten for sure this year I absolutely
love that it strips away a lot of the
relationship stuff that took over that
took the series over yeah that was not
usually the norm for emblem and it sort
of became the norm yeah some people like
that but for people who don't like
myself yeah yeah it makes this game
stand out that'd like the odd dungeon
stuff
I love the the controlling two armies
for those who haven't played or no no
you have almond Celica and it's it's a
really
imagining of the first game or imagining
of a game called fireman gaiden which
was sort of like at the time even a
weird offshoot on the Famicom now and I
played echoes like I think people are
saying they beat it in like thirty five
ish hours I'm at hour thirty and I think
I'm about to beat it but yeah you're
controlling these two separate armies
building them up it has of that I don't
know maybe there's a weird comparison
Suikoden to vibe of kind of building up
an army with different characters that
you recruit or I guess like all Fire
Emblem games but oh my god I fell in
love with it so much like my love of
XCOM I want to play Mario Plus Rabbids
but this in terms of the turn-based
stuff it's also very hard but I'm
absolutely in love with it just figured
I'd shoot that out there because I don't
think we talked about it once when it
released but I finally got around to it
and it's absolutely I love it yeah today
you haven't played Final Fantasy Tactics
sadly I've started on the Vita but then
I start playing this it was very
outdated was the word he's just sedated
I got I was mainly just grinding you
goats alright cool so we let's talk
about Metroid Samus Returns you are
essentially done with it right
so embargoes courtesy of Nintendo we
can't we can't give like we can't leap
it up the review you can get a score no
but and I can't talk about the last boss
but I can talk about absolutely anything
which includes how much I [ __ ] love
this game yeah B I played five hours I
told you or like four or five hours I'm
like absolutely got this thing right
here because playing up right up until
the show went live oh man this game is
really good there's a lot to dig into as
well yeah to start it's this is a
reimagining of Metroid to return of
Samus yeah do not think of it as like a
remake and an additional sense because
it takes the basic premise which is ok
there are Metroid's on this planet we
don't want the space pirates to get them
and like take over the universe so we're
gonna go send some you know some crews
out there go kill them well those crews
never heard from again
mm-hmm alright well we gotta send Samus
she's the only person who's ever fought
in Metroid so we're gonna send her out
there and so this is the game you are on
sr388 and you were there too just a
radical Metroid's at the bottom of the
screen you can see 32 that's 40 at the
beginning of the game and it represents
the number of Metroid bosses you have to
beat and they scale like some are more
like a mid-boss
some are more like traditional bosses
but that's
essentially what you do is you defeat
Metroid's you unlock these gates that
are based on the old like you know sort
of Egyptian like alien race known as the
chozo they have these little gates we
have to like give them Metroid DNA to go
deeper into their civilization yeah and
and you do that and that's the basic
premise the you know structurally it's
very different from the first game even
though it shares that same gated
mentality because you have one large map
that is interconnected you are not
moving from one phase to another like
you did in Metroid 2 yeah there's years
of Metroid mini-bosses
yeah this is one of the this is the
Alpha Metroid I think and so the
different metro is you fate you fight
represent the different stages of
evolution of the Metroid you know be the
ones we're all familiar with for the
most part are the larva the sort of
jellyfish looking one amiibo yeah and he
just saw you absorbed it's like DNA and
then that was that unlocks those gates
that you were mentioning there's kind of
like a set number of Metroid yet to kill
in each area yeah but and then you could
see the map down here there's a lot of
new things Samus can do I don't know if
we've seen it yet in the b-roll but
people might have seen it when they had
showed it at e3 she's got this this
melee counter-attack for when enemies
charge and that it's tough to pull off
at first I'm getting the timing down but
they're different enemies attack which
means so different enemies attack at
different speeds so you can but you can
essentially just like stun them and then
it automatically aims like a power shot
at them and then you just smoke them and
it's really useful for the Metroid's
like you know that was immature - okay
so I never played metrics you played a
lot of the first one in Super Metroid
and all the primes and I'm excited as
hell for Metroid Prime for but I was
telling you then you were saying this
game really focuses on the action aspect
of it it's maybe it's between the melee
counters you can hang on a ledge and
shoot and do the melee counters while
you're hanging in in general like the
360-degree aiming with the analog stop
and hit his shoulder hold down a
shoulder button and Samus can aim I mean
really it's like 270 degrees or 180
whatever but yeah she can aim in any
direction so if she's facing this way
she can eventually turn and fire that
way without really moving oh yeah
actually I love the what like her stance
when she shoots buying
she's like yes like this this [ __ ]
pose that look just well man I look but
uh oh she's sick you got some dough
farmer there so that's just the Varia
suit that's what you might recognize
from Super Metroid just withstand heat
it does help you withstand heat there
are a few different suits you get
throughout the game
one of which we can talk about in a
second because it's a little
controversial but oh here we go this is
going to be a chase sequence so oh this
is yes you got the spread gun too Brian
Oh does that open those doors with the
eyes I was wondering so this is like Ori
in the blind forest now sure I mean if I
guess okay this game is not Metroid 2
necessarily but it's also not super
metroid even though it you've got a map
you've got hidden items everywhere I
mean like that broad structure is the
same but the way that it emphasizes
action relative to exploration is very
different like it it likes to put you in
tense situations where enemies are not
just sort of standing there waiting for
you or they only have like one or two
attacks you're often bombarded like
quite a bit from all angles or you're
being chased like this and this is a
three tiered chase sequence I'm just
going through the first section right
here and so action is sort of the
moment-to-moment thing but you again you
still explore for hidden items and you
want to find them but the key difference
here is you don't actually have to poke
and prod every single block you actually
have an ability that will scan the
nearby environment and on your map
highlight I know based on these little
blocks this great system where your
items are and you might think well that
cheapens the whole experience of hey I'm
exploring these things and you know you
know going into the depths and hoping I
find some great riches that's still a
challenge even though you can locate
things because there are often little
mechanical environmental puzzles
involved to get the item that you can
see yeah and also you can kind of see on
the lower screen here that yellow bar
that dictates certain powers you have
and that's sonar pulses map so that
sonar pulses map to that and you
replenish that by pairing enemies or
just defeating them you'll get more for
parrying and you know less for just
defeating them outright there are some
chozo ruins that just give you full they
will replenish stations yes yeah you can
get replenishments as well
but so it's it's a nice little
advancement for the series to find a way
to incorporate action and keep
exploration but also freshen that up
because so many Metroidvania games have
come out yeah and so many of them revel
in that blind item hunting experience
that what Metroid has to do something
different right it could be just what we
played in Super Metroid with a new map
and people would be happy but I'm beyond
happy with this game oh yeah I am I am
I'm thrilled that it is the way that is
and I'm really happy that I've gotten a
chance to play it I'm at the end and I
can't wait to replay it again and it's
not just about knowing the map or small
different bosses
it's about getting through these sort of
harrowing experiences by the skin of
your teeth and it makes and to point out
like you kind of mentioned it you don't
have to use that sonar pulse if you just
don't press a you you could keep
shooting walls like the old-school way
but it takes out the overwhelming aspect
of like oh my god like yeah I'm right
right to point to a recent like two
years ago I believe axiom verge of very
very good Metroidvania and they were
going very much for that classic you
know spend hours you might not know
where you're going looking for things
and then also like what else came out
this year dead cells that early access
game which is phenomenal but that's more
of a you know you start over and you
kind of gain permanent abilities a
legacy without the procedural generation
look I know it is procedurally generated
and that game is fantastic holo night
was really good I finally got around to
playing that a few months ago that's
kind of more that's still a Metroidvania
but they don't give you any direction at
all really and then also in the the Dark
Souls vein not the combat but you
actually will leave like this corpse
behind that you go back and kill for all
the money you got but you had whirring
the blind forest even kind of met Rivini
aspects like but like you mentioned this
reminds me of breath of the wild where
it was almost like Nintendo was kind of
seeing what everybody else was doing and
not the Nintendo Nintendo had producers
on this game with mercury steam the
developer moto the guy who's made every
game except Metroid 2 Sakamoto I played
today so which is kind of funny because
like the one Metroid game he really
wasn't involved in was the one that he
is essentially in charge of overseeing
the remake up yeah
but maybe that's good and and I
it is I'm only five hours in you were
much much farther than I am but it feels
like breath of the wild in that they've
come out and yeah they've done new
things to the formula like breath away
Liz I think is the best open-world game
ever made that comes to mind I mean I
will say that the the credit is mercury
steams all right Nintendo approved their
their whole action focus but they
brought the idea of parrying to the
table they brought a lot of the
action-oriented stuff to the table and
that's based on some of the work they
did for Castlevania mirror of fate mm-hm
which was you know they made lords of
shadow which were those big 3d action
games very own Castlevania like but then
they made the 3ds game which was trying
to be a real Metroidvania in that sense
it had this like weird over emphasis on
combat which involved like quick time
events and [ __ ] like that so who knows
how much they presented to Nintendo I'm
sure Nintendo help them refine their
idea but this is a mix of two parties
who had really good ideas or at least
really good direction and this is a
result despite the fact that this is
mostly made by mercury steam it feels
like a Nintendo made game also taking a
shitload of trust on Nintendo's part to
trust someone with eight like what
Nintendo fans have been asking for for
years now like a return to 2d Metroid
but we were talking about this earlier
let me look at the platform it's on
right this is a sort of the minimum risk
they could take to make this game right
they have someone else make it and they
put it out on a platform that is
presumably cheaper to develop for then
switch yeah so if this does well I
wouldn't be surprised if we saw you know
a new game you know put on to switch or
we saw this game ported to swish I would
hope yeah but that could happen because
I know I'm not really playing my 3ds
much these days the first game since
echos alright where I've wanted to play
it mm-hmm
yeah it was like this whole last two
weeks has been echoes and this for me
like I haven't put this thing down but
it's like Metroid Prime for have they
said it was gonna be next year happen to
know obviously that's great I love all
three much our games especially the
first and the third but or sorry Metroid
Prime game especially the first and
corruption the third game but I I was
excited for that but obviously like the
thing a lot of people have been asking
for at least within like the old-school
diehard and Tendo circles is a
two-dimensional that's my Metroid it's
been 13 years yes since what was the
last one
Game Boy Advance I think it was either
zero mission or fusion I think zero
mission
it's like I forget what the order was
for those two yeah it's been a long-ass
time so the one misstep which I kind of
hinted to earlier was one of the pieces
of armor that same as can wear the
fusion suit some of the communication
from Nintendo was a bit wonky yeah it
seems to have been clarified and it kind
of sucks is that you can get the suit
for Metroid Fusion and we're in this
game and it's a more difficult version
of the game when you have it you can
only get that through an amiibo now that
on the one hand you could say well me
both cost as much as DLC typically so
hey you're just getting DLC but it's
shipping on the on the cart it's already
there it's not like it's coming out once
after the fact like they had to make it
and they needed to somehow recoup costs
it's you know whatever they're shipping
this game with us on there they're
making you buy a Toyota unlocking which
kind of sucks there is a harder mode
that you will unlock after beating the
game but it's not the fusion suit mode
look I love a me bow or wolf link from
breath of the wild kinds comes in mind
breath the wild used a lot of like
specific items to amiibo right yeah what
were you saying it was particularly with
the with the armor and this one that it
was like so it awesome it changes your
abilities and admit and the mode that
you use that armor in is a little bit
more difficult so it's a unique run
through the same world but the issue is
you have to buy a toy to get it now
maybe down the road in Tendo will DLC to
play devil's advocate what's the
difference between buying an amiibo to
unlock that and just buying DLC because
it's on the cart at release oh okay I
see what you're saying so it's there
just this unlocks it yeah it's like you
bought the cart but you don't get back
into it skating today it's already done
yeah I mean like I I would argue that
the breath of the wild amiibo stuff is a
little less impactful yes absolutely
like I think that it sounds like this
isn't entirely not entirely different
but a a unique take on the game that
would increase your replayability and
it's a different a different way to
experience the game versus having the
you know a certain bow and breath of the
wild didn't drastically change my
experience with that game and I'm here
at the end of Metroid saying I want to
replay this and maybe that's hard mode
but like
I mean we have the amiibo I haven't used
it yet because I want to just beat this
game and some of the amiibo give you
like extra energy tanks and [ __ ] like
that which is good but like I don't want
to get to that point but I do want to
replay this game and see what that feels
like without the fusion seat
mm-hm then redeem the fusion suit and
feel like okay well what does this
really mean mm-hmm the concept of it
doesn't detract from my enjoyment of the
game I still think really highly of it
it's just one of those things where it's
like by the way it's a huge bummer we
should know about
it's a bummer and it seems kind of cheap
it seems a little cheap but but here we
are with the 2d Metroid that's excellent
that we haven't seen in over a decade
and I can't get too upset about that
yeah I want to get more to like it
overall Nintendo stuff but I do have a
question from 84 gesture X and the
YouTube chat he or she was saying even
though length doesn't really affect a
good metro game how long is it from your
experience well based on my experience
which was I wasn't really using the
pulse thing well enough to begin with so
I ended up doing a lot of backtracking
like find hidden items I maybe didn't
need to and there was one boss I got
stuck on not because it was like too
hard but I wasn't sure like what to do
to damage it during a certain phase
that's like a little bit more time than
maybe other people would need I'd say
over a dozen hours at least it depends
on how you want to play yeah and I also
want to point out that uh Samus Aran
in the YouTube chat just joined didn't
say anything else just put the emoji
with sunglasses and that's it nothing
else love that respect she has not said
another word there's not much else to
say unless you're in Metroid Other M and
then you've got we have a poster of that
hanging in our lobby is that like it's a
good poster that poster I never got it
but know that game it I don't know if
you ever played that game but it has
like story moments where Samus is not
her usual self and she's like talking to
this commander and she's very like
sheepish and like he's the one in
control and it's like that's [ __ ] Sam
it's like what the hell Samus is the
boss you don't [ __ ] put her under
someone yes sir yes sir yeah shut up
yeah yeah Kim's weird yeah and then um
we have what else is coming out for
Nintendo the rest of the year Super
Mario Odyssey and then we have a bunch
of third-party titles
assumably it is Xenoblade Chronicles 2
mm-hmm
but that looks people played that it
packs actually I think I don't know if
we got the chance to
Xenoblade I played oh you did oh yeah oh
what no way that quick yeah sorry I
didn't think I'd thought of the switch
stuff is separate from packs I'm sorry I
should have brought it up for talk about
packs
yeah it was it was really it was
gorgeous
the battle system seemed very convoluted
on paper it's basically you have what's
called a blade and it's sword sort of
like a familiar but it's like you you
get different powers and you can kind of
swap between blades and at first it was
super overwhelming and I was like okay
stop just swap between them and then I
have to get to like certain tiers of
attacks to get a final attack but in
practice it's actually super smooth
the battle system I really enjoyed it I
thought for a jrpg it was kind of a cool
like I was letting my teammates do what
they wanted but you also have this
collaboration aspect where you can chain
attacks based on your party's attacks
and so I like the battle system a lot it
seemed really involved and the world was
gorgeous it seems like it's going to be
like the first thing I played Chronicles
a really substantial RPG and it's coming
to switch so I'm very excited to
actually get deep into that and you
don't have to play you don't have to
have played the first one to play this
one oh no no so it's totally separate
and I can't get over how beautiful it
was like you're inside these giant
flying beasts and like that's where
humanity makes their homes and it was
the level design the monster design is
really great so I'm excited to play more
play handheld that docked
I played Fire Emblem Heroes as well or
warriors sorry farm warriors that really
soonish right October yeah that one was
I really like Musso games I think that
they captured the fire a little thing
really well with that as well
there's like a pairing up system with
really satisfying attacks that seemed
very true to Fire Emblem how you can
kind of like you know if you position
your to part two people next to each
other and they have combo attacks they
make out real quick they make out
Milas just really gently that was good
then I also played Skyrim once much for
a little bit that I played handheld oh
yeah so I guess that's a good transition
so we have Skyrim on switch we had
Nintendo partnering with Mercury steam
to bring out Metroid Samus Returns we
have them partnering with Ubisoft
through Mario plus or Abbas which again
was a great game from what I've heard
like across the board breadth of the
wild came out and it was in my opinion
like the best open-world game ever made
it's up there now
we're talking more Metroid and it's
fantastic we haven't have a score or
anything Metroid for 3d a Street I might
switch ok yeah yeah this is our I wanted
to talk about this cuz that's talking to
Pete the other day about this after he
had played Metroid him and hyping it up
we were drunk at a bar
yeah and I'm mostly sober right now and
I still think isn't endo is uh it seemed
like this year in Nintendo was like
finally back in a big way like they
weren't they weren't always completely
gone right there on they had some great
games on the Wii U but it wasn't than
like what we were wanting it seems like
they're not as sheltered now they're
working with all these different
companies these third-party titles
they're coming out they're bringing
their big guns with breath and a while
it's amazing I gotta keep in mind these
deals were struck back when Nintendo was
struggling in our yes when they didn't
know what they were doing but I mean
it's like this seems like a lot of their
stuff they've been biding their time
with has been coming to fruition this
year especially the switch there's a
Forbes article that PU pointed to in
Japan the let me pull it up in Japan the
switch has been initial sales for the
ps4 in Japan we're a little bit higher
when you compare them side to side
they're almost on port they're basically
on par is that yeah but the switch sold
more its first six months and the ps4
did in Japan yeah
quickly the ps4 quickly went is like you
know the thousands yeah
whereas switch stays like hovering in
the tens of thousands yes and it sells
out every single week oh really
afterwards like after that six month
drop were you saying they had drops to
the thousands for ps4 drachez thousands
have been a couple weeks so it was even
six months Oh was it that big of a gasp
so
it's like double okay so in short during
the first twenty six weeks on sale
according to Forbes in Japan the ps4
managed to sell 665 thousand units
whereas the switch sold 1.5 two million
units that's double yeah in a pant and
it's selling out I'm curious what the
sales numbers are like here everywhere
else outside of Japan all you I know is
this [ __ ] selling out there would be
more sales here and there and everywhere
if they're always best and it's it's
like and it's it there's a supply it's
not like ass Ness classic thing like
there it's a small supply there they're
trying to make 1.5 notice yeah what was
that line that they were they were
flying switches out because demand was
so high despite it being like a
significant like loss and profit or hey
like we did the numbers we just ship
he's a dude I mean you're kind of
looking at right now but this is ps4 and
the right column apologies this isn't
great for people watching switch on the
left like after so switch was 329
thousand its first week ps4 was three
hundred and nine so ps4 got a little bit
of a bump after that in the next few
weeks sixty five thousand thirty five
thousand twenty nine after that is start
dropping off into the four digits switch
just kept increasing to ninety eight
thousand in its 21st week sixty nine
thousand is 26 week that's just that's
just as many is antenna yes just a man
Japan right yeah yes I wonder have the
numbers up for uh I was but I was about
to start thinking about like the you
know the whole console wars type
situation right we're like that initial
six months you still had your your Xbox
fans may be splitting up but this is
Japan though right yeah Japan doesn't
have Xbox but you know opposed to yeah
I mean if it was here I'd maybe you
could argue that but like it's nothing
but good for even if you're like I have
to imagine if you're an Xbox player if
your ps4 player this is just gonna
create more competition and I feel like
it'll push them to start doing new cool
things as well like Nintendo is killing
it this year I mean again Ivan played
Mario Plus Rabbids but like it like the
Wii U like it was there if you could go
seek out the good games right and the 3d
s always 3s library in my opinion is one
of the best on a platform in general but
now it's just there in your face the
switch it's selling really well the
games are doing pretty well it feels
like it feels like one of my main
consoles now I don't
I've been using the office which I don't
even have when I played a ton like it
speaking things it's beginning to feel
like now is you know back when it
launched
I was asked should I people ask me like
you know like friends of mine should we
get it I was like well it they're Zelda
personally that could last me for the
year I would hold off and it's becoming
like a factor of like hey we're about to
hit October with Mario Odyssey and that
I mean that's just like the straw on the
camel's back of like yeah you should get
one like despite there being splatoon
Rabbids yeah I mean their games realloc
splatoon and arms we're not talking
about those games so really good games
and you got Mario Kart on there as well
re-released sure but a little game
called rocket League and then I didn't
notice it I mean it packs they had like
oh they're full nin DS lineup yeah a lot
of really strong indie support on the
switch and I think that also helps make
it feel more like a main console rather
than my console that plays the Nintendo
games I want to play you know what I
mean so like when I was I was demoing a
like visual novels and stuff and a lot
of them are coming to steam and switch
specifically one that I played called
necro barista which I am very excited
for but I thought it was cool I thought
it was really cool it's like okay of all
the platforms you could choose going
towards switch just is another another
step towards being like this is a this
is a main attraction it can be on my TV
it can go with me like there's there's a
lot going for this way it's a good place
for those those types of games to live
because they're not completing competing
in a marketplace against a lot of
triple-a stuff
yeah which you'd think they'd be had
knock against the switch but it really
is it isn't it yeah all right let me let
me backtrack really quick because rile
the rise you in the twitch as seems
pretty angry that or not we didn't talk
about another Metroid to remake that the
remake that the yeah you are yeah so so
uh so we might haven't played yeah talk
about yeah
we have not play that game unfortunately
like is it is that the one that got that
was pulled by Nintendo if writes ago and
across the board people seem to like
that a whole hell of a lot and it is
more of a straightforward remake of
metroid 2 yeah the fact we didn't talk
about it doesn't mean we don't think
that it's necessarily good right we
haven't played it yeah we don't get to
play every game that comes out
unfortunately and yeah it's interesting
that to bring a game like that back they
had to go to this like right fan remake
right front ends like fan revival the
aim to our yeah yes yeah but then like
we said we have mercury scene come out
with this from a me and you would say a
very fantastic two-dimensional Metroid
yeah I mean I don't even think you can
compare the two because from what I
understand they're different games yeah
but yeah anyway sorry they were they
were asking us to play it's 84 Chester X
who also asked earlier about a question
said it's it's freaking fantastic cool
so that's rare word for yeah I I do want
to wrap up my thought really quickly and
that's all it's all I was gonna say it
was you have the console like they're
really like traditional console on my TV
super robust full-length experiences on
the switch and then you also have curl
up in a chair in bed playing stardew
valley or that's bus yeah you have those
more bite-sized experiences i think they
that's so far they've done a really good
job of introducing a mix of those things
yeah for both types of player yeah it's
like it's like the Vita but done right
right as the Vita tried to recreate I
think that experience that people know
on something like PlayStation 4 right
the switch has got the form factor and I
guess the Vita wasn't really convertible
but whatever it's got that at it on top
of it it's got that handheld sort of
high quality gaming experience with
different games
I guess what you can also play a TV yeah
it's that new mind yeah you're on point
it's like that new mindset now where
it's like oh man I wish I was I wish I
was on the switch like that thought has
has been lingering around my head like
when we talk about like next machina
right like oh I love that game so much
but yeah man it would just be perfect to
have on the go because the formula of
that game right like oh you know I'll
get a couple you know 10 minutes 20
minutes and I can put that thing down
like so
this is so great this is you know having
a turn-based game Zelda is amazing but
like that's a game where it's like I
don't know I have to like have
headphones in I have to be it's like a
dedicated down light the candles did you
mention Snow Valley
yeah the last word from what is it
concerned eighth as the the developer
the last word was that they're still
working out the kinks but that it's
still technically I think the official
release window is still 2017 but um that
I think that's subject to change but I
am very excited about that because that
is a game that I had on my on Steam and
I have a desktop PC I don't have a
gaming laptop so all the time I'd be
like I just want to play this game in
bed I love this game I would play I play
stardew valley for like straight-up 8
hours straight like I love that game uh
and I'd be like if only I could play
this on a soft cushioned surface while
you're pooping you know how I'll be
moving yeah I mean then we also have
metroid prime for to look forward to you
and the new like switch exclusive
pokemon yeah when the helps pokemon snap
come in to this high right I played a
lot of Pokemon snap back in the day a
lot of apples on you know it I mean some
you know what I you know what
it's the perfect dude perfect platform
for pokemon stadium everyone gets a joy
Khan you go to town yeah you're like
very mini games game just brought some
life think about Micah stadium was you
brought your characters through a memory
card and then you you bet you didn't
have you could it was it was more
focused around just battling and then
you like I know but you couldn't raise
them on the 64 game you couldn't like
catch them and raise you could rent you
could rent poker so you could be like
I'm borrowing this Charmander for my
battle I'm sick
put a loan on I'm gonna stream them on
Netflix I think will be a present option
in in this game so cool they must be you
like thinking of some way to work
without think about this for Pokemon
snap right there were eight people
talking the other four are in here
chimes yeah the the Pokemon Sun and Moon
ultra are all coming out this fall but
I'm not much excited for those because I
didn't like Sun Moon is even when they
released yeah so I
I like Sun and Moon and I understand why
people wouldn't but I think that as a
Pokemon game they do a lot of things
right ultrasound and ultra moon I am
really only excited for because that's
where the next competitive series is
going to be played I don't know what
else they will offer me and I haven't
been convinced yet that they will offer
anything different or special or new but
you need the game to play in the
competitive series for 2018 so I will
get it if they bring the title into the
game world
we're like there is an ultra Sun our
whole framework has changed the world is
what we thought it was how do you print
okay
Kelly arrow lamaze has a he's always in
our chat he has a specific question
through twitch for you oh man this is
gonna make me sound stupid how do you
how do you pronounce this game Pete
which one I can't Siri : legend real
edge 'end was sure combination of
Pokemon stardew valley I'll be on switch
in 2018 I don't know it sounds like
right up your alley sounds like
something I'd like they're all just
saying what do you think about it so I
think will that really quick I think you
should tweet a wink at me because co-op
monster raising RPG by Magus -
Kickstarter I don't know how to
pronounce that like Ari legend but a lot
of anime have that same title or it's
like recalling something like the
Kingdom Hearts games here we go thank
you John Luke looks like a bravely
default character like danger is very
close to 18 - switch yet stardew valley
+ Pokemon if you guys aren't gonna see
me
for the entirety of next year I feel bad
for Harvest Moon having lost like being
a representative of its genre harvest
harvest moon has fallen so far yeah I
used to play a lot of harvest
well Harvest Moon had the it sucked
because the licences got traded around
and the actual series is called story of
seasons in Japan yeah and then it got
like a different series was dubbed
Harvest Moon here and then a proper
Harvest Moon finally became story of
seasons over here the most confusing
timeline for a titled series yeah
question I think this is the [ __ ] you
see switch Xbox one and ps4 I can't wait
to play like we were just saying it
seems like it begun switch oh that's a
sweet sword whoa if forging weapons to
two of them what is this rainbow swords
oh my god oh so there's also the game
someone what's the game that Double
Fine's publishing through their indie
program that's like Pokemon Oobleck
bullets yes I realize also we played had
them on the e3 stage few months ago and
that game looks charming and fun so is
this what this is like real-time combat
yeah with Pokemon next to you sprawling
some farming aspects they're just going
for running the gamut portal the hell
yeah I just start fighting okay turn
portal there's concern date the sturdy
valley people are also doing a magic
school RPG like wizard school so there's
there's a lot of games that are like
right on my alley coming out I'm very
Stokes games are cool sorry games are
great side now did you hear Magic School
Bus is coming guy that's great it looks
like they're all using like the animals
they hunted for armor I was a hell of a
trailer but yes go back to what we were
talking about it seems like Nintendo is
really pulling out the big guns this
year making the switch sell in Japan at
least and I'm selling over here if like
how many times it's sold out or
is any indication they have a really
good year it's really really nice that
like one of the big three is actually
acting like it again it seems like or at
least they're putting all those plans
into motion to be back up there and
competing hopefully this just Spurs more
competition with ps4 and Xbox one and
people on all the consoles get better
games what is this I Pete nothing no you
can talk nobody it's just me and you a
poor Xbox oh I know that you I though
back down three is getting push back I
like expires when you do well I'm happy
with grad was the gamescom announcement
a German become crackdown 3 huh Age of
Empires what about that that is the only
new recent announcement for Xbox that's
so weird that that's coming to a console
when RTS like that yes Jurassic world
creator
comes tomorrow yeah
wait what the director's no the Apple
does not work oh yeah actually you said
Jurassic Park creator what am I supposed
to think
[Music]
Ranger it's it's it's like it's like
rollercoaster tycoon
someone in the chat just said pub G
coming Xbox one as well that's I'm
excited for that but that's not a
thunder exclude it's not a reason to buy
that platform yeah I feel bad for them I
don't hate them don't attack me on
Twitter thank you you're gonna eat are
you is your phone blown up already the
last time I said that we're doing so hot
I got like an onslaught from dudes with
like I would love to box the oboz in
their names for weeks
oh you didn't even [ __ ] on Xbox you just
said a fact you just said that they're
not doing very well anyway whatever I'm
on the internet what do I expect yeah I
really hope Xbox does well in the coming
months and they can play I'm sure like
I'm sure they need to have a halo 6
announcement sometime in the new
I can't be that can't be the thing I
can't just be another healer but it is
like that's what they have right now
that gears five you know crackdown three
got the delay I was excited for
crackdown three but now that I mean like
the delays make me worried but I'm also
glad there seemed to be taking their
time with it but also good huh that's a
delay that's needed and they said they
announced that game too early yeah
Jurassic Park builder I think according
to a pax penguin he might be joking
though he jokes a lot in the chat
jokester yeah so let's let's hope I
don't know Nintendo was doing really
well it's nice to see them getting back
up their Xbox let's hope they start
pulling more weight and giving us a
reason to get it Scorpio may beard axe
whatever it's called I still call it the
Scorpio cool so I might as well talk
about destiny to now bend a bunch of
questions now we are getting to it I
have someone thought through Twitter
that I'll get to but uh Cal you've been
you played like twenty hours of it up in
Bellevue a few months ago yeah you we've
all been playing it Robbie Nye think I
wish fifteen yeah I'm like lovely I play
Metroid a long time last night when I
could have been playing destiny but
you're you're reviewing it you're
reviewing progress is up overall just to
recap those impressions what are your
thoughts of the first 20 hours well so
to clarify I didn't get to finish the
story so I didn't really conclude my
story impressions but the main thing is
I think they did a much better job this
time around with context to
contextualizing the things you're doing
we've talked before about how destiny
has this really great feedback loop the
shooting feels great and a lot of it
wouldn't work without a great foundation
with you know like weapon handling and
how how enemies in shooting works I
think in destiny too they did a
fantastic job so far from what I have
played of giving more context to the
things you're doing to differentiate
those actions from the other times you
would be doing similar issue that makes
sense so fighting one group of fallen in
one adventure mission that has context
that the context for one mission for
example is like you're setting up comms
to get refugees from the last city to
come to the farm which is the new social
space so they kind of interconnected all
these things and you know fighting those
enemies feels distinct from fighting the
enemies you know on Titan where you're
doing you know structurally a similar
mission but for a different reason and
with different context and I think they
did a better job of introducing this
story and the lore this time around and
so overall I feel like I have a reason
to keep playing
I felt like my reason before with
destiny one was just so I could stay
caught up with everybody else who was
playing this I feel like oh I I have
more of a reason to play you know
getting loot feels like an
accomplishment again to me it's it's
refreshing I'm digging it so far yeah so
far like I definitely agree I think
taking King was a step in the right
direction in terms of providing more
context for what you're doing kind of
giving you some sort of motive which
isn't always necessary destiny like I
know they pulled a lot of the writers
off to do other things on the first game
so they only had a few writers kind of
like providing that context now they
have a full team but I will say they
made like doesn't want an especially -
it just feels almost flawless in terms
of how it plays like dig mechanics
themselves and they need to be if
they're gonna have people playing this
for a year or two straight like almost
like you know every Dave in some cases
but now it feels like there actually is
this overarching world that's kind of
enveloping you and that's not always
necessary but I think it is here because
it's such a cool world and people want
it to see more of it well I do think
it's necessary to justify coming back
day after day right you know you had to
find a reason other than just I like
grinding you know I am there's things
that I like that I am gonna you know
reserve final judgment on until I can
try them out in PvP like I like the new
weapon categories right but I haven't
really tested that out in PvP for me in
PvE feels like a lot of variety and I I
feel like the game is showcasing it's
fantastic weapon design right but I I
know some people are nervous about that
in PvP and the way the new weapon
categories will affect that so
you know there's things that I'm still
kind of hesitant about but I've played
mostly like single-player stuff I played
some co-op last night that was really
seamless strikes
I played I've done one strike so far I
haven't really done a lot of strikes so
yeah that's that was like my ending foul
last night at around like 1:00 a.m. was
just like getting a new weapon and
trying it out and just like all around
just such a unique and like varied
arsenal that you can like every weapon
it's like this gun is cool and then you
get a new gun you go well for the most
part it's like I was cool calm but you
know what I can't like I lost come
better and that's always tough to like
you know dismantle a weapon but what I
was gonna say was oh yeah touching on
your context like for me I'm not one to
speak a lot about destiny because I did
kind of fall off but yeah like
contextually I didn't import my
character and I wanted to like to have
you explain that one thing or later but
like going around and interacting with
objects I didn't I don't remember this
ever being a thing in destiny we're like
you you do that classic ghost
interaction but what you get out of it
is a very vague but like interesting and
maybe foreshadowing sometimes a bit of
dialogue that you find along your way
this is I get again for the most part
like the main story but I know you can
find these things everywhere
they're called scannable Zipes cannibals
it's totally that that's at the Costco
that's that's right that's exactly it
but it's great to like just engage or
something and then just have someone
have chatter with you as you're walking
through a really awesome breathtaking
environment that was very rewarding but
yeah if you want to talk about you just
told me this before we went live and I
found that freaking awesome yeah so in
addition to like I think dialogue in
this game does a better job I mean so in
destiny one if you're not familiar you
could unlock grimoire cards and you
would get kind of lore information
they'd have to read online or on the
and so it was really cumbersome right in
this in destiny to a lot of it is
through dialogue it's a you know a
little more a lot more integrated into
the actual game itself and one of the
cool things is playing co-op with
somebody last night who imported his
character from destiny one I switched
from Xbox to ps4 so I have like a new
character and we were comparing dialogue
and the dialogue changes based on
whether the game thinks you are a new
player or a returning player so when I
encountered the taken for example my
dialogue was basically like oh the taken
are you know this kind of thing there
distorted species like the fall and I
got like a basic lowdown on what the
take in our four person I was playing
with he got a thing like oh remember
when we beat Oryx I thought the taking
shouldn't be here and so it was a
different kind of dialogue but still
serves to introduce the take in in the
context of destiny too but it takes into
account your experience and what you
should already know so I thought that
was really smart it's a good way to not
over explain to returning players who
know what the hell the Fallen are and
the take in and all that stuff but it's
also just it helps kind of call back to
all the time you spend destiny one yeah
bunch of minor things as someone who put
a decent mount of time into the first
destiny that I like a chief Lee among
them is something I didn't even know
that they would be showing public events
on the map and when destiny won there
was a certain site that tracked them and
they would say go to this part of the
moon for this so that's really nice
that's a good little quality-of-life
thing yeah and the public events are
important because you can get loot drops
from them that help you unlock here
other subclasses and I believe we're
doing a guide on that so check game spot
for that later but many guys many many
guys but it is it's nice to be able to
track them because they're a little more
useful and it's it's it's also nice I do
want to talk about this a little bit one
of the other things that I talked about
in my review in progress is the variety
of things you have to do in addition to
the context surrounding those things
does help to break up the repetitive
feeling even though you
are doing very very similarly structured
things and so you know when you're
grinding there's a there's a - there's
two missions in the story that are level
gated and so in order to you probably
will be like two or three levels behind
if you just kind of play through the
story without doing any extra stuff and
so to do that grinding to get up to that
level you can do an adventure which is
kind of like a story mission esque
activity you can do on a side quest
compared to like put patrols yeah you
can do a patrols patrols are there they
do exist they're very short form if you
played the first deston you'll be
familiar with them adventures are super
long form and you get better loot from
them there's lost sectors which are like
dungeons there's public events there's
heroic public events there's basic
looting and then there's collecting
tokens from around the map that you can
exchange with that areas and PC for loot
so there's a lot of different ways to
level up and get new loot and I thought
they did a great job of introducing
those and giving giving you options
based on you know what have you already
done do you want to do more lost sectors
or are you bored of that because you did
six today already or even do you have
enough time to do an adventure maybe not
maybe I'll do a patrol or two so I
thought that was all really really smart
and it was nice it was it was nice to
have options some things to do and so
just being like all right how many
patrols do I have to complete before I'm
level 13 I I was like yeah I was
consistently surprised with the variety
of adventures for something of such
quantity right it was like there was one
I did last night that was pretty well
designed it was I was on this planet
here it was like just kind of like hot
potato with platforming I love that
there's like it's a series of three
platformer
so yeah it was really fun and difficult
you're on these vex platforms and I am
NOT a huge fan of destiny's platforming
but idea yeah I was surprised I liked it
cuz I never really cared for Destiny's
platform but this one is there's like
vixx platforms and they're they're
charging them separately and so you like
figure out and the charge is gonna hurt
you so you have to like jump from one to
the next
and it was actually like it was like
it's a silly concept it was really fun
and you're like getting information
about the VEX as you do it just another
thing that's like oh now I'm learning
about the vex which are the coolest race
and destiny by far I love them they're
absolutely the coolest it's pretty
vexing that you just said that oh god no
and that's the thing is like in destiny
when I could've been like I did this
patrol or I killed the thing and if you
like yeah but this one was like oh I did
this hot potato and I knew exactly what
are you talking about yeah they're
distinct and they're like they they feel
like proper missions it's yeah it's it's
not just platforming you know it's
you're doing a mole a multitude of
different like things within this
objective year trying to get info one of
these platforms is something you need to
get and so like it might be you know I
think this is it if he pulls it up
exactly ya know this this looks like
it's it so what was funny was to have
your brain go like okay like I'm gonna
time it cuz all the while you're
battling like you know a series of like
right here yeah you're predicting when
it's gonna be on and off and while
dealing with enemies and while listening
to like the story and the story was
super entertaining like what are the
characters on each planet that you've
kind of first interact not like that
they're just like the planet NPC I think
is what they're sure but like but you're
interacting with and getting a lot of
you know your quests there's and quest
killers yeah so a lot of times they're
having conversations with your ghost and
I found all these characters so far too
pretty I want to I wouldn't say I'm like
in love with them but they're at least
on a third eye I like failsafe which is
the one on on Nessus I like I like felt
like yeah there's other ones I'm not as
big a fan of but it is cool if they
listen I know they're entertaining to
listen to my I see to does a much better
job of keeping them involved throughout
the adventure the question yeah that's
someone you would get the quest and
there might be one line of dialogue
it would usually be Zavala or okayed
more up yeah exactly and they would be
telling you they would be talk to you
every once in a while but then the
actual one who gave you the quest
whether it was like Saladin or anybody
they would it wouldn't really these
characters remain part of the quest
throughout and then it's pretty cool
that it'll run into him at the end doing
something in it
yeah like when you tell sorry when you
tell celaya what's the first girl's name
at the Hawthorne Hawthorne Celaya or
Syrah that you have to go do something
else she's like legitimately pissed off
we need your help
what the hell you call us right sister
psoriasis it's neat to come back to each
plant though and have a familiar look a
familiar style of music the music is
really great but also a familiar chatter
with like your ghost and this this
character like for this princess this
character here is asked maybe I don't
wanna spoil it if i disappoint like I
don't know it's the closet the
conversations are like memorable and and
I don't know I just it's it's refreshing
and the other thing to like what I want
to talk about was like the pacing of
like enemies where if I remember the
first game your throne the hive like
within the first like two hours oh yeah
the hive alright immediate and I got
very much like a halo feel time
basically the flood yeah it's it's a
form of alien that like will just you
know freaking like come at you non-stop
they're an infestation exactly
it's it was neat to like have that
pacing drawn out of like different enemy
types opposed to like just like having
it all randomly thrown with no contacts
into your face like I don't it reminded
me of Halo and I like that a lot
that's my point I will say the story
isn't groundbreaking by any means I
think it's I think a goal which is the
main enemy is basically Bane from Batman
I don't know if anyone else got that
vibe
but he's basically bein well he gives
this speech where he's like I had a hard
life for now and yeah but in a club call
I think it's at least told more
cohesively which makes the things that
are you know actually very good about
destiny shine more just flying upwards
these public events by the way these
ones we have to fight the Cabal and
there's like like missiles that come
down at you
I was playing one last night where
everybody but me died and I had to
revive everyone because they just got
annihilated I think this is a warlock I
can't tell ya I'm it feels like with
taking king of the stuff in the right
direction for Bungie to say we're
listening to what people want we are
making corrections to what the vanilla
game was to from my perspective so far
feels like that it's that times 10 like
this is what people want this is what we
want to do with the story is what we
want to do for like quality of life
things this is you know it remains to be
seen how these weapons will work out in
PvP like you said I don't know it from
your perspective do you think this is
Bungie like kind of making good on what
the first destiny could have been oh I
stand corrected this is a Titan and it's
Hayes footage um Jun sorry yeah I think
this is basically like rather than
starting out or vanilla your one destiny
started out this is like we're beginning
with taking King levels of involved
story activities to do I'm very excited
to see where they go with that like what
if this is the platform that they're
building on I'm excited about that
I'm excited to see where they go a while
back in the chat I put this in the show
because it's a good question there's a
good observation 84 gesture action the
YouTube chat was saying so far destiny
too seems to be doing with titanfall 2
Borderlands 2 and even from what it
seems battlefront 2 will be doing
sequels that are kind of what the first
games should have been or at least what
we hope they were I agree with titanfall
2 I would say that was a very good
improvement on what I wanted the first
game to be battlefront 2 it seems like
that's what they're doing
I hope Borderlands 2 I played a ton of
that game same thing but yeah it's
like like I just kind of mentioned it
seems like this is destiny maybe not
like you know the quintessential destiny
experience but they're getting there
yeah what it's supposed to be I I will
say I'm not I haven't played enough to
be sure that this needed to be a sequel
rather than an add-on I think it's nice
to have a fresh start I think a lot of
people were kind of upset that they had
to give up all their gear and stuff as
somebody who didn't have a lot of people
to play with and therefore didn't really
grind for like the best gear that wasn't
a problem for me anyway but the fresh
start is also nice than that they've
changed a number of things that it makes
sense to go in new and fresh I guess but
at the same time other than the fact
that the story is two years after the
events of the first game I'm just not
sure yet I need to play more for sure
yeah so at this point now like how many
hours he played like 30 maybe total like
yeah I was so far your initial
impressions of this better than they
were for the first destiny yes I think
this has been a positive first
impression um I have had to replay a lot
in this first day because at the event I
played through stuff on a dummy account
so that's why I'm saying I kind of need
to feel it out more on my own account
and see how I feel about the loot system
and stuff like that but it has been
positive and even replaying it I'm not
just like it I'm not bored it's the
missions are well-designed enough that
I'm not like oh I have to do this
mission again which is nice if you're
creating characters in every class so
cool
so destiny 2 is out Xbox one ps4 right
now it's coming to PS PC unfortunately
for people who are waiting for it on
October 24th we have all been playing on
mainly ps4 or more platforms whenever
possible
I think everybody's enjoying it so far
we'll have more stuff coming from
GameSpot all week we have like guides
and features and whatnot yeah that's
pretty much it
sidenote hopefully this isn't too inside
baseball you just mentioned that they
had the dummy character at Bungie have
you heard the story about so I found out
that I was reviewing taken King
and I also hadn't played destiny since
before the dark below so I was really
behind yeah and then our boss comes
obviously hey probably it probably be
good for us if you can get to the max
level and I had like oh you didn't need
to ahead like two weeks before the event
which that's like three weeks worth of
time so I just like Eric Tay was just
carrying me through a bunch of things
and I'm like it was it wasn't a
nightmare video game it was still fun
but it was still a grind for like two
solid I just I picture myself slow zoom
well it's like oh my god I'm just
playing with this Titan that they just
whipped up an hour before the show it
was funny one day I'll look back and
laugh on this so here we are
oh my god it's gonna pee gears sorry it
was literally like hiring a trainer to
be like no give me give me five making
raw eggs that's that's how I wasn't I
was reviewing rows of iron but I didn't
I said I had to level up my account so
it was like oh god but the dummy
accounts have really funny names which
is nice what were they
mine was riotous not sorry I think all
Sandra's was respect your elder like
prison of elders um there was respect
your elder Shaq's me anything see I
wasn't I was problem wild which I didn't
I was like whatever but like shacks me
anything was everybody's favorite how
that was a good one cool so like I said
well have a lot of dusty stuff I had
games on GameSpot throughout the week on
our YouTube channel and on site cousin
shared daily updates on her yes
progress will be updated I got a sneeze
so tell him what the plan basically
we're doing a daily diary entry just uh
here's the things that I did today and
my impressions it's gonna be pretty
casual I guess tweet at me if you have
questions
woo yeah and also to get to the giveaway
this is good transition because it is
destiny related jean-luc will pull up
with the image we have for you it is a
destiny two coloring book a twenty page
poster book you can see that on the left
actually well that's
collection I don't know what some of the
posters looks like and journal from
insight editions who did this this
collection
the art of destiny to title will be
releasing November 28th from inside
edition's and yeah as always shiva who
managed our twitter account she might
put in the twitch chat right now the
link to that tweet from gamespot if you
don't already follow us on Twitter do so
and then retweet that giveaway tweet
will pick later in the week random
winner for this giveaway as always yeah
we'll be announcing that via Twitter
we'll contact you if you are the winner
the lucky winner that's the show it's
good to be back I think I might be going
again in a couple weeks but we don't
know for sure yet but yeah we never
really know what the future holds for us
unless your own backs unless you're a
vaccine you have complete control over
space and time or amy adams in arrival
no just kidding
haven't seen that yeah yeah so shiva
just put the link in the twist chat if
you're there here in the youtube just go
to twitter and follow us and retweet us
if you don't already
we're like my digestive system slowpoke
overlay for Rob's face I don't get that
his intestines control space and time
your intestines are the vault of glass
that's yes yes yes dude you're all you
are good today let's hang out more if
the rest of the day it's good work I'm
just want to hear some of these sick
puns thank you so much everybody for
joining us in the YouTube chat twitch
chat GameSpot as always we will be back
next week the raid for destiny 2 will be
releasing on the lobby day but I think
as of now yeah I don't even know if you
well you might not even be I might just
be raiding it ok so we'll probably brain
we're in the corner but my brain like
he's back there we'll see if Shawn
Luke's back there next week rap is a
cool idea we've talked about that
thank you what you just we just do like
a status check on the raid and we've cut
to it every so during doubt there's a
phrase we use that we use to cut and
we'll just randomly say it and we'll
have to cut the calories I'm Joe
sweating
we have a water bottle like it's like
some text Bob Jones says Rob seems like
he's in deep thought say I would I would
argue that but yeah so of course damn
back next week with that I think he's
dreaming destiny to pretty much all week
he does probably you can stay tuned to
twitch every day at 11:00 or YouTube or
GameSpot live to watch Eric play some
destiny - he's leveling faster than any
of us as usual except when I beat him in
that bet good job getting the taken king
great job we made a bet and I won I'll
never let him forget that it was destiny
- as those memories that come on yeah
yeah it shows it shows like whoo you did
these certain events with and it said
taken King and it said Irish X my PSN
and juice and gin oh-ho remember this
when I beat you that it was like 3:00
a.m. yeah man man remember that good
times people see it on knievel all the
time no one actually cares I know
everybody for some Bob will be back next
week and we'll be streaming all
throughout this week's and destiny - see
you then
[Music]